from just being here for like the last
hour so I get the sense that you're very
disciplined maybe that's the wrong
assumption but you seem very disciplined
to me
do you ever procrastinate and I'm sure
you do but if so what are some of the
things you catch yourself doing that
you're like oh you know what I'm
procrastinating this isn't real research
this isn't working
and how do you combat that well I think
social media is certainly kind of you
know such a you know big part of our
daily lives today so for me is managing
that you know trying to be you know
connected to it in the sense that you
can communicate with people but not you
know let it steal all your hours away
you know for me that that's kind of a
big thing time management you know for
me you know is is kind of like a lot of
artists and storytellers out there
working in Los Angeles there's so many
people out there who are talented and
who are have great ideas but they're you
know they've got their survival job you
know they've got auditions so they've
got you know families and they've got
dogs to walk and kids to care for you
know and and so all those things are not
excuses they are real parts of people's
lives you know and I think that's the
thing that I've had to try to explain to
my my family and friends about the work
that I do the work that a lot of my
friends do the work that a lot of the
people you know do you know people say
well how do you deal with the rejections
and I said well I can deal with the
rejections that's just part of it you
know but it's really at the time
management you know trying to figure out
which meetings are important to take and
you know which jobs that you have to
kind of turn down because it's not
inspiring or whatever you know so social
media is a big thing that gets in the
way
having to pay rent is a big thing that's
in a way you know having to find money
to do grocery shopping is to get you
know you know all the things that kind
of get in the way for for everybody you
know but I think this business is
especially kind of unique in a sense
that you have to kind of go out there
and create your own path you know which
is what melissa has done and I think I'm
so proud of her is that she is a
talented actress and she's you know been
around and and and but there was
something about that kind of complacency
that she just was not happy with and I
think and that's that's what I think mmm
another reason why we connected I know
you wrote for film courage calm in 2011
I think was it for night dream blues
right might have been for that and I
know that that got a lot of hits it did
very well and I think part of it was to
you were very open about a lot of things
and one of the things you said and I'm
paraphrasing here is that you would go
after these little bit parts with a lot
of zeal and and zest and really go after
things and then you realize you were
sending the message to yourself that you
weren't worth more or maybe I'm reading
too much into it but that you decided
you really wanted to step it up because
in terms of going after bigger things
because you were sending the message to
yourself the universe that I'm only
worth these little bit things right
right yeah and I think that's an
interesting topic because you know III
wrote about that from the perspective of
being a minority actor you know where
parts are not kind of coming down to me
as often and when they do they're not as
interesting and something that we wanted
to attack in all I want the feature film
is that Melissa you know as a woman you
know how often in even in today's kind
of like
you know landscape of filmmaking you
know to have a strong female protagonist
is unfortunately still rare you know and
so that was something that she was up
against you know and so we connected on
that as well and so I think part of the
reason why she wanted to kind of embark
on this journey was because as a female
actress a storyteller she was not kind
of getting access to the kind of stories
that she felt she was really interested
in telling you know oftentimes the
female role is kind of just you know the
girlfriend who is upset at the main
character you know blah blah blah and
she wanted more than that and and I
think that was something that you know
that we talked about during this film
was it was really kind of making this
film really have strong female
characters and so this film is special
in the sense that it's got a strong
example across the board but it's got a
really kind of an interesting a female
kind of energy in a sense that there is
this you know there is the storyline
about all these different female
characters that I think is really
prominent that I really enjoy what about
for you though when you made that
decision whether it was 2011 or whatever
where you said you know what I want to
only have a certain standard for myself
and it's not and I'm putting words in
your mouth right but so please stop me
it's not that you feel maybe that you're
better than that but that you want more
right right personally emotionally
career why all these things yeah how was
that when you would maybe let's say you
I don't know how you choose your roles
or how you choose what you want to write
but that you would use this test and say
I don't know if that's the level I want
to be at how did you start deciphering
that aside from write this project I
mean like just in general because
obviously that led to this product right
right right
I think it's an ongoing kind of process
I don't think it happens overnight you
know I think there are a lot of moments
what you for me there were a lot of
moments where I knew what I didn't want
knew what I wanted and then there's this
kind of you know part of this phase of
negotiating that you know you know I
mean if I want to write that you got to
go through all the work of writing the
script and then you got to go through
all the work of raising money and then
there's all these kind of voices in your
head that say no no no no no just just
that's too much work you know and so
there is definitely that phase and then
you know after I don't know how long and
then you start to for me I started
writing in the theater and so the
journey was very long you know I started
writing in 2004 you know and I've
written you know several plays that's
been produced and and and so my kind of
quote-unquote playground figuring out my
my voice my instrument started in the
theater you know and then and then went
through short films and feature films
and and so I think I think you know
after you've gone on so many auditions
for one line you know for a character
that that might be cut out during
editing you start to kind of lose
interest because you have a bigger story
that you want to tell you know so I
don't know I think it happened over
years you know happened over years of
realizing that I wanted to take you know
more control over the stories that I was
involved in
you